mais oui mais oui tante adélaïde j'ai
passé de très bonnes vacances oui j'ai
bien mangé oui je me suis lavé tous les
jours oui enfin presque oui comment mais
non je t'assure je ne te cache rien non
je n'ai pas attraper de rhume et l'oncle
archibal s'est très bien occupé de moi
c'est ça howard tante adélaïde
c'était ma tante adélaïde et c'est
chaque fois pareil chaque fois que je
vais passer des vacances chez mon oncle
archibald
elle craint que celui-ci ne s'occupe pas
assez de moi chez elle c'est vraiment le
contraire tout est préparé et organisé
on gère mieux est chez mon oncle
archibald
je fais ce que je veux c'est comme ici
sur l'île aux enfants je fais vraiment
ça que je veux bon allez d'ailleurs si
je veux être à l'heure pour mon cours de
danse avec julie faut jouer dépêche
alors il me faut ma canne makan la voilà
il me faut également mon chapeau de
forme et il a qui vont être dans la
malle moi j'ai en voyons
c'est pas ça mon chapeau haut-de-forme
voyons
ce qui te prends casimir d été comme ça
tu les as faim mais comment cette malle
est à moi et tout ce qui est dedans
également avait pas du tout va bien
longtemps craint plus rien ne
t'appartient dans cette mare comment
comment je croyais avoir rangé ici mon
chapeau haute forme et avant qu'on
arrive et même
alors un chapeau noir
alors hein je croyais que plus rien à
parthenay dans cette malle quand c'est
vrai tout est à moi maintenant mais le
chapon j'ai essayé tout trois points que
le m il est vraiment trop grand
il est vraiment trop grand rien qu atre
la veine que je sois prêt ces renards de
malheur fait pas toujours ce qu'on veut
et bien moi justement si je fais ce que
je veux et j'aurais danser avec julie au
revoir
au revoir
tian bonjour
je suis en train de relire mon livre de
poèmes
je vous en dirai s'appelle à que la
terre est belle il a décrit par pierre
nothomb a que la terre est belle crie
une voix là en a que la terre est belle
sous le beau soleil chaude elle est
encore plus belle vous grenelle
escargots lui encore plus belle quand il
tombe de l'eau
vu d'en bas vu de la terre est toujours
belle et vive l'hirondelle et vive
l'escargot
[Musique]
carte ou tard je m'appelle tuna
si quelque chose me menace
je rentre dans ma carapace
épatant
je suis appuyé sur l'usure de la plus
belle des paru
par contre je suis une tortue
raisonnable
paraison c'est ma passion mais dire mon
occupation
[Musique]
tout art je m'appelle tout en
lui quelque chose mais maintenant
je rentre dans ma carapace
m
nous raccrochons se référant je n'avais
pas assez de foi
à
ferro de la raison mais si j'ai un
esprit trop peu pratique
dommage pour le drame lyrique et zut
pour les mathématiques
[Musique]
kraft ou tard je m'appelle tout à
fait quelque chose me menace
je rentre dans ma carapace
pas tant la carte graphique c'est
l'événement le foot
c'est toujours agaçant les ragots je
fais le quai
ensuite enfui de grandes traces de la
plus belle des cuirasses
tout un tas
je m'appelle tuna
mais quelque chose me mena
je rentre dans naccarata
fabien barthez
salut
françois oui je vais tu n'as pas vu
casimir ah non non pas encore dont julie
oui tu as changé de tenue oui nous
allons répéter notre danse alors comme
ça je vais être plus à l'aise formidable
travail bien fait puisqu'il n'est pas là
je m'exerçais simple
léonard qu'est ce que tu fais là comme
enjeu national je suis venu te voir
danser avec quasi
intime et ben c'est toi qui devrait me
le dire a commencé ta croyable je suis
pas chargé de janvier casimir la guerre
ni les partis ni un bon moment de la
maison avec sa canne et son chapeau
ne t'énerve pas il est peut-être en
train de parler avec ses petits amis
lapin dans le petit bois tient pour te
faire patienter je vais te donner un
bonbon à la menthe
mais voilà ma voilà j'arrive à moto
magazine et espacés à ce ce n'est pas de
ma faute j'ai rencontré le facteur qui
m'a demandé de porter un paquet chez
monsieur du snav oui je porte-paquet
monsieur du snop me demande à son tour
de porter un tableau si mademoiselle
futile enfin un tableau il fallait voir
son nom heures comme d'habitude
je porte au tableau on loisel si tu me
demandes l'accrocher au mur à jeu
lagrange est à un coup de pouce aux
doigts alors évidemment elle l'a perdue
mais c'est partir sans me faire le con
cement alors ça a été des petits canaris
en sucre petit lapin geôles en chocolat
et on sait lui même cette fois petit
renard obligataire
qu'est ce qu'il veut
bombay coup de casimir au travail bon
d'accord d'accord
quand je vous dis oui est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas changer de musique un peu
écoute casimir la prochaine fois là tout
est prêt je prends mais la prochaine
fois on fait une nouvelle d'un bon
d'accord attention musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh là là quelle journée je suis épuisée
et journée je sens plus enfin bon et
qu'est ce que tu as fait j'ai fait ce
que j'ai voulu mais moi aussi 3 les
semailles
tu n'as fait qu'est ce que les autres
ont voulu tue environ 5,1 à monsieur
justin tu as clown au mur le tas de
goldman sachs chuté tu as dansé ce que
julie avait décidé mon pauvre casimir tu
n'as rien fait et qu'est ce que tu
voulais mon pauvre léonard tu es un
ignare c'est à dire que tu ne ne connaît
rien à rien tu ne sais rien et tu ne
comprends rien bon on peut très bien
faire ce que les autres vous demande
tout en se faisant plaisir à soi même un
tut tut tut décision est pour ça que
l'on ne fait pas ce que l'on veut
dans certains cela mérite réflexion way
en attendant passe moins car
si je veux
[Musique]